To finish up our last problem, we simply simplify the denominator. The cube
root of 3 cubed is 3, the cube root of x to the 9th is x cubed, and the cube
root of y to the 6 is y squared. Remember, the whole idea here was to
rationalize this denominator. We wanted a denominator that didn't contain a
radical. So we multiplied by enough factors underneath of a cube root, in order
to change our denominator to something that we could simplify. For our
numerator, we just had 1 time this cube root, and then we simplified the cube
root, 3 squared is 9, and then I have my variables x squared y squared. We know
we can't simplify this cube root of all, since all the factors only appear
twice. And it's okay that we can't simplify the numerator, because our ultimate
goal was to rationalize this denominator. We wanted to get rid of this radical
symbol here.